Samuel leaves here and in this video we
wanted to look at the question our HMO
properties oversaturated now right now
I'm on vacation as you can kind of see
and I haven't got a single room empty
which is amazing
however this isn't really about mean
about my portfolio so I decided to
interview a guy called Neil Brown who's
just bought and he's just buying some
HMOs up north and we can ask him to give
us some stats in case studies the audio
sound is not amazing so we have got
subtitles I hope that helps
[Music]
I'm good Thank You Samuel we've now got
ready
diehard property fans that are itching
to know whether HMOs work up north so
hopefully you'll be able to enlighten us
I'm going to ask you some questions
you'll be able to share your story I
mean why don't you just kick off by
where are you currently buying your HMOs
right now I'm currently buying in Hull
in the Northeast in whole in the
Northeast are you a full time property
investor we just starting how long's
this been going on now I am a full-time
job in the corporate world so my
property investing is very much evenings
weekends and an early morning here and
there when you bought your first house
in home planning on doing as a HMO what
did people tell you well it's a very
good question quite a few people want me
that where I was buying my HMO in
particular was oversaturated with
existing HMOs mmm okay interesting and
did that worry you I'm it did and it did
put me off there were times when I
really thought long and hard
there were times you know where I was a
bit concerned about it fortunately there
were also people who are very successful
as well and want one of the big lessons
here is to be careful who you listen to
interest in so how do you determine who
you listen to and who you know well I
always happy to listen to everybody's
views but it's a case of when making my
own decisions to really consider which
views are most appropriate so it's a
business decision am I going to listen
to somebody who's never invested in
property or am I going to listen to them
investors with significant HMO
portfolios
however one thing that I've learnt is
that there are several types of HMOs a
lot of fun the standing off the HMOs
very
variable and having visited a lot of
them what I learnt was if there's a HMO
with mold and Dan really badly
maintained these were generally the
people who are having the voids correct
yeah give me an idea that so the first
item uh that you bought in Hall I know
you've spent money on it to make it look
nice but how much did you buy it for and
how many bedrooms were in the house the
property has five bedrooms
I paid fifty eight thousand pounds and
spent thirty two thousand pounds doing
it up so the grand total of nine
thousand pounds which you know I have a
rough rule of thumb I must eighteen
thousand pounds per room okay before you
before you go on with the biggest so you
till you've bought a house you've spent
90 grand on it including the refurb and
that's how many bedrooms five five
that's brilliant excellent I mean
congratulations finding a deal that good
but people are saying the area's bad
you're not gonna rent the rooms out and
all this kind of stuff that's right to
achieve with that property well I'm I'm
a very I consider myself to be reverse
so I I used the figure 75 pounds per
week per room based on a double without
an ensuite so I know that I can achieve
that and anything else is a bonus okay
now I'm going to ask you the big
question now so you are hoping to get
300 per room a minimum approximately
that's three six nine twelve so you were
hoping to get 1,500 pounds rent per
month people said that you wouldn't do
it what what you went in the house out
for now eight it's amateurs that's 80
pounds a week program which is one
thousand seven hundred and thirty three
pounds a month boom
congratulations I'm really pleased for
you so good job you didn't listen to the
to the naysayers I mean that's that's
astonishing return on investment I mean
Oren house for 90 grand including the
refurb I'm renting out for 1750 a month
I mean of course you've got constant
expenses on that so nearly ask you
question what separates because there's
a lot
interesting HMOs enthusiastic but they
just never do it so I mean what would
you say would distinguish someone
between being a success and not having
any success at all what would you say
would be the key factors I think I think
a lot of it's actually in the mindset
what the key aspects is I'd have a
really good supportive environment
around you throughout the purchasing
process when you know buying a property
that cheap it was balanced to have a lot
of problems and it did it wasn't it
wasn't the easiest transaction and there
were there was more than one occasion
where considered walking away from it
and you know this week once seeing all
fully refurbished seen it fully let it
was it was the moment I look back at
those moments where I thought about
walking away and pulling out and I
realize what a great decision it was and
it's that having that supportive
environment so when when you do hit
hurdles there's other people you know to
mastermind with to help you out because
yes I have a mastermind group somebody
in that group will have had a similar
problem or know somebody who had that
same deal and and we know how to deal
with it yeah brilliant
so have a good mindset get around good
people be part of the network and
mastermind of people who are cheering
you on bouncing ideas off each other
crucial so what you so you've done that
deal what other properties have you got
going on what I've done okay I've got
currently guts off is accepted on to
further properties they will also be
five beds HMOs I'm now scaling the
business up working with investors so
that's you I can leverage my skills
experience and some of my time to work
with other investors work to go to scale
of business up expand the portfolio I
say to two deals already agreed I'm
hoping to exchange on one in a couple of
weeks time
the other one it's a bit further behind
maybe about six weeks away how does it
feel to be a professional and successful
property investor well it's this lot
this last week was a good week for
celebration as it was the end of the
most recent projects so another key
learning from the over the last year's
actually been to celebrate that success
so I just booked my tickets the
Madagascar hey Congrats that's amazing
you deserve it well done I mean why are
you plans for the future because you
said you've got a full-time job but you
got all these deals coming through you
know you're making two grand a month
went off this one property that you
bought for fifty or thousand pounds
you've got another couple on the go what
what your plans for the future at the
moment it's an expansion phase once once
I get to where I want to be it'll then
I'll then go into a consolidation phase
and I have plans you know my passion in
life is to travel around the world my
number one value is freedom so it's that
freedom to do what I want to do - with
no restrictions and adventure is also up
there in the list of value may be a case
of living to those values a lot more oh
cool that will allow me to do that
I'm a you know what that sounds
absolutely wonderful money in education
and being part of forums and masterminds
you know now now it's time to celebrate
and have some freedom so brilliant
Congrats
what would you say more questions before
we before we wrap up so firstly hole is
known as a cheap area it's thanks very
far
you know north side of the country I
mean people from London say the arm from
the north because I'm intended oh we
know
what would you say to somebody who said
do HMOs work in northern areas
like oh and Salman's asking you for
advice what would you say I'd say they
do work you just have to do them the
right way you know you know I'm
expecting you know expecting that the
HMO regulations you know licensing
coming in I think really important that
when you get involved in these projects
do that due diligence you know visit the
properties see the property speak to
people who know the area you know local
knowledge is just so important because
there are parts of all where you want
you know where HMO won't work yeah and
some of those they're not far from the
areas where it does work and it's that
local node that's so crucial but yes it
does work you just have to do it the
right way like every strategy to
property investing there's always you
need to know what you're doing you can't
blindly just randomly buy something and
hope it works because his biggest box
box check market research rules to
consider so absolutely excellent so let
me ask you a final question what advice
would you give to somebody who is just
starting out in project firstly it would
be to understand why you're getting
involved in profit in property and then
once you've got clear on that to to
understand what you want to achieve and
how are you going to do it it's it's the
planning stage it's so important and
once you've got clarity everything else
starts to fall into place
excellent well listen it has been
amazing talking to you congratulations
once again with all your successes
thanks for the information content
you've given to everybody watching on
the video I'm sure everyone would agree
it's been absolutely fabulous and keep
in touch
thank you very much Samuel if you want
to have a chat with Neil and loads of
other investors like Neil that are
successfully investing across the UK and
also connect with myself then why don't
you connect to our Facebook community
you can do it by clicking right here
absolutely free all I ask for in
exchange is that you share this video so
that others can see what really is
possible - what are you waiting for
share share share share this video right
now thank you so much
[Music]